air tag not reachable
move around to connect bobby
and i left
oh wait
allow me to explain this is my fanny
pack
and attached to it is an apple air tag a
new 29
gadget that you attach to items you
often lose so you can find them using
your iphone's
find my app this is wasabi a
professional detection dog
that can sniff out the most hidden of
items and well i think you can tell
where i went with this whole thing
i put this air tag and other competing
lost item trackers like the tile pro
and samsung smart tag up against
wasabi's nose
in a series of indoor and outdoor hiding
challenges
because well yeah my dog only moves for
bacon
do anything and since many have been
asking if air tags could be used as a
pet tracker
there you go we put one on wasabi for a
separate challenge
of course alyssa wasabi's owner and
professional narcotic canine handler
with 3d
canine was along for the whole ride
ensuring wasabi was happy
healthy and hydrated all right
here we go challenge one fanny pack lost
in the house air tags and other lost
item trackers
use low powered bluetooth to stay
constantly connected
up to several hundred feet away
wasabi's sniff range it depends on a lot
of factors
but about five feet in every direction
for this challenge we had him sniff out
drugs uh fake drugs more specifically
a substance that smells like heroin yeah
definitely
smells but it's absolutely not heroin
it's used in canine training
instead of using my nose i used my ears
for this challenge
when you're in range of an air tag you
can press on this button in the find my
app to sound an alarm on the tracker
itself
so i had my producer kenny here hide the
fanny pack someplace inside my townhouse
then i'm gonna wrap it you can't hear
the dangles
of course wasabi found the fanny pack in
one minute and 20 seconds
yes
me and the air tags okay not so quick
i knew it wasn't on the basement floor
because don't hear anything in here
when i hit the second floor apple's
precision finding feature came in super
handy
it says connected but the signal's weak
so it's not in this area but i hear the
sound
tap find nearby in the app and it uses
ultra wideband technology
which is more precise than bluetooth in
very close distances
if you're within a couple of feet of the
item and you have an iphone with ultra
wideband
the iphone 11 and up it can guide you to
the item with on-screen directions
fanny pack may be on a different level
than you
unless it thinks it's upstairs in this
area
and so what
bathroom nearby
here whoa i found it
got it i also tested the samsung and the
tile in the same location
the samsung and the tiles alarms were
louder and i could hear them clearer
from the second floor
but they lack ultra wideband so no
detailed on-screen instructions about
the direction of the object
the winner obviously
challenge two fanny pack lost outside
the planter and you can't see it from
the street all the trackers apps
show the location of where your phone
and the tracker were last connected
in this case where i had the fanny pack
last standing on this street corner
but apple's find my network goes a bit
further
anyone's iphone in the real world can
report the location of an
air tag think of it as an invisible
network whenever an iphone passes the
air tag
it anonymously and unknowingly picks up
that bluetooth signal
and the location of where it picked it
up the owner of the air tag can then see
the location
in the find my app tile and samsung have
similar networks
but in this case it's likely that no one
with a participating samsung phone or
the tile app on their phone walked by
but a billion active iphones in the
world is a big air tag selling point
the find my app says that it is on the
corner of newark
over there tile has no idea where it is
but once that find my app led us into
that 10 to 15 foot range
wasabi took off
all right so if i'm standing over here
it's on the corner over here
no no
damn you yeah you wouldn't have known it
was over here wasabi if it wasn't for me
winner air tags
challenge three dog lost all right
go anywhere within 10 mile radius
turn your phone on airplane mode and
wait there
before sending them off i equipped
wasabi with two trackers
an air tag and the whistle go explore a
real pet tracker
with the whistle i had a live gps view
of where they were headed
the device connects to att's cellular
network which is why in addition to the
150
device you have to pay a subscription
fee and it says that
wasabi is currently on freedom way
you zoom out that seems to be liberty
state park
turn left onto freedom way
with the air tag it was similar to the
lost fanny pack on the street
i had to wait until someone with an
iphone came into contact with the air
tag at the park
to see the location
wasabi ah i see wasabi over there
are you so impressed that i found you
the winner
the whistle though the air tags held
their own plus the whistle drops battery
quick
the air tags have replaceable batteries
that are said to last up to a year
so what do we learn here today well that
everyone should get a wasabi
but really air tags are very good the
lost mode feature needs improvement
it sucks that you have to buy an
accessory to make sure you don't lose
the actual air tag
and despite apple's anti-stocking
features i have fears about these being
used secretly to track people
but if you often lose things the only
other real option is to
well not lose them guys i gotta get a
real dog
i love you browser i love you